hoy Brasil ha elegido a su presidente es
Luis y la célula da Silva que después de
12 años vuelve al poder el 1 de enero
empezará su tercer mandato ha sido una
victoria difícil un resultado apretado
una victoria amarga que supone una serie
de cosas primero el voluntarismo ha
salido reforzado de esas elecciones
además la gobernabilidad va a ser muy
difícil porque el 2 de octubre las
elecciones legislativas tanto la cámara
de los diputados como el senado tuvieron
una mayoría consonarista en un país tan
polarizado Lula va a tener que hacer un
esfuerzo muy grande para conquistar el
voto de la oposición a hacer muchas
negociaciones en un país recordamos que
mi residencialista esto quiere decir que
el congreso tiene un papel fundamental y
eso lo vimos en 2016 con el impeachment
de que fue alejado del poder preci por
una decisión de los congresistas además
nula ahora por fin va a tener que
desvelar qué va a ser con a la economía
en su campaña él se ha limitado a
repetir lemas bastante ingenuos Y
genéricos como vamos a ser felices de
nuevo o vamos a comer picaña ahora va a
tener que decir que va a ser para
contener la inflación el precio de la
gasolina y sobre todo cómo piensa con
tener los ambiciosos planos sociales que
quieren implementar Luna durante la
campaña pidió un cheque en blanco a los
electores basados en todo lo que hizo en
sus dos mandatos de gobierno llega ahora
el momento de la verdad para demostrar
lo que sabe y lo que puede hacer